startling research shows black girls are
much more likely to be punished in
school than white girls time and time
again we've seen disturbing videos of
school resource officers and teachers
using violence to punish young black
girls as part of our school matters
series we spoke to a thirteen-year-old
who says she was dragged outside and
left in the cold by her teacher in the
second grade she's featured in a new
documentary trying to ensure this does
not happen to anyone else
extreme punishment of black girls in
schools is more common than you may
think
according to a 2007 teen study by the
National Women's Law Center black girls
are more than five times more likely to
be suspended than white girls and are
six times more likely to be expelled me
getting into big trouble
thirteen-year-old samaya Dillard and her
family are not surprised by those
numbers samaya story was featured in a
new documentary called push out the
criminalization of black girls in
schools in your own words what happened
in the second grade I was basically
bullied or felt bullied by my teacher
she said in second grade an argument
with another student led to her teacher
dragging samaya outside she then grabbed
my chair that I was sitting in and
dragged me across the room to the door
and sat me outside outside outside like
outside in the cold yes and this was the
day before Christmas break and then what
happens I just decided to leave their
story made the local news in Sacramento
second grade girl walked away from her
Natomas school and no one knew where she
was for more than two hours you were
near freeway and the documentary you say
everything could be easier if I just
jumped yeah you thought about ending
your life at the age of seven
I was feeling confused and helpless so
Maya's parents settled a lawsuit against
the school and the teacher the school
district issued a statement saying in
part we hope that her story and the
stories of others will help other
districts as it continues to help us
it's stories like some ayahs that pushed
educator and author
Monique W Morse to raise awareness
through the documentary you really begin
to pick up on the stories across the
country you start to recognize that this
is actually a pattern of violence
against black girls what do you think is
at the heart of the disparities that we
see with young black girls black girl
hood and womanhood is constructed by
these ideas in our society of them being
hyper sexual of them being loud and
angry women the film was screened last
month at the New York Metropolitan
Museum of Art and will air on PBS next
year we're never gonna make it they say
my life is not a success they say I'm
problematic because I'm bold I want
people to walk away from this
documentary understanding number one
that our girls are not disposable and to
really think about how we can shift our
understanding of what constitutes a bad
attitude or sassiness or combativeness
mo Canady from the National Association
of school resource officers acknowledges
there is a problem we're training
officers to go into the school
environment and to realize that implicit
bias exists even their own and how to
combat that the end of the day a good
sra really should want to have positive
impact on the lives of students
psychologist tiffany Munford dent hopes
to make that positive impact and school
systems need to begin to identify
prevention strategies and actually buy
into them having worked in juvenile
correctional facilities she now
organizes in-school therapy sessions for
girls outside of Cleveland Ohio we also
need to show black and brown kids that
we care about them being here that the
goal is not to push you out of the
school system we have to
pair the relationship between schools
and black communities fundamentally
believe that schools need to be
locations for healing so that they can
be the locations for learning what are
you hoping people take away from this
film we are people too
and that we want to be heard black girls
are loved and sacred more said she has
interviewed more than 150 girls
educators and justice professionals and
visited more than 30 communities
throughout her career doing this
research you know it started off with
her book and she really talks a lot
about black feminine identity and just
how it has been constructed in a way
that you know you're not surprised that
they're treated differently black girls
are treated differently and say
differently core numbers we see the
videos we cover them on the air here and
you think I wonder if there's a trend
here there is a trend you know so I
think just exposing that and her PBS
documentary she's having a conversation
about it is really important everything
starts with the conversation and
everyone seems to be on board now so
maybe a follow-up to see if things
actually change alright thank you very
much